the jurgen experience you know the two
promoters of that
girl fight as you put it the girl fight
yes
eddie hearn you're gonna make me have to
have those girls on and apologize
[ __ ] um
and jake paul
jake paul was a promoter yeah without
jake paul that fight doesn't happen he's
you know he's a like a full-on promoter
now
yeah absolutely
the kid's got a hustle you gotta give it
to him the kids got hustle he is a
successful husband i don't know i think
he might be he's got hustle or he's not
a hustler this guy is a legitimate
businessman yeah a legitimate
businessman but the major but
he makes so much money doing other [ __ ]
that the fact that he wants to do that
as well and promote fights as well i'm
impressed he put her on his undercard
she got a lot of visibility there people
in boxing of course were already
familiar with her but it gave her much
bigger notoriety by being on his cars
and then he and eddie hearn put this
fight together
again i can't stress it enough i sold
out an actual madison square garden sold
out main arena fight that's bad
good for him that was the value for
dollar like sunglasses yeah he's doing
the same
i like it i don't think this fight
happens without him you know the the
conversation he had with eddie hearn
where he says
i will knock out any one of your guys
that has under 10 fights right he goes
whoever you want to have bring me any
guy that you have that's under 10 fights
you can see eddie hearn like [ __ ]
he's kind of stuck there because yep
because those guys under 10 fights like
what if jake paul knocks one of them out
like what if you get a guy that like
hasn't been tested and maybe has some
promise and maybe gets wrapped up in the
hype and maybe gets a little nervous and
this is his first chance at a big big
big show and
jake paul can crack
yeah a hundred percent that knockout of
tyron woodley is legit as [ __ ]
okay crack but eddie's point in that
interview and i think the point that
just about just about every boxing
aficionado
would say is that
tyrone woodley is not a boxer yep and
norris ben askren who he knocked out as
well right we would have gotten some
answers if tyson fury didn't get injured
or excuse me if uh
tommy tony fury didn't get injured
leading up to that fight because he was
the initial opponent so if he fought him
we would have got some real answers and
that would be an interesting fight but
agreed and to your point i saw people in
boxing when that fight seemed actually
was gonna happen start hedging their
bets well fury isn't this tommy isn't
that i don't buy any of that i think
tommy is a
absolutely a legitimate boxing opponent
for
jake paul entertain this perspective if
jake paul wasn't jake paul if he wasn't
this youtube guy he was just a boxer and
you see a boxer knock out the former ufc
welterweight champion not just the
former but one of the best ever knock
him out with one punch like that like oh
man have you seen his jake paul dude
coming up he's [ __ ] for real because
nothing about watching him fight to me
screams like he's in over his head
nothing he looks like a real boxer he
looks like a real boxer he doesn't look
like a guy who's attempting boxing
that's the difference the faints the
foot movement the way he lands shots he
fights like a boxer he doesn't fight
like a guy who's trying to box in a
celebrity boxing match he fights like a
boxer no because so if he wasn't that
guy i'm saying if he wasn't that big
youtube star and you just saw him as a
boxing contender you'd be like that
dude's got dynamite in his hands
okay so there's two points to be made
here first of all if a guy
in his pro debut and the first five
fights of his career are knocking out
people whose names we know
you're absolutely right that person is
going to get a huge amount of attention
and everybody's been like wow who the
[ __ ] is this guy
but also
er
if
a guy who is on the track to be somebody
who has like oh potential from the
olympics or he's got a great amateur
record we're gonna turn this guy into
somebody
in their first fights
they're fighting
guys who are like
five and 27. they're fighting other
uh debut opponents who don't have a
great track trajectory in front of them
they're fighting you know tomato bums
yeah you know
just
completely not competitive just to get
experience
and that's fine
right so
when we expect
jake paul to be fighting like higher
level competition it's not because he
has under 10 fights because he talks a
lot of [ __ ] yeah but that's also why
we're talking about them and that's
that's exactly true but i think on both
sides of the equation we've got to like
admit that
a young fighter under five fights isn't
fighting great competition so if you're
calling jake paul a legitimate boxer and
then you're expecting him to do what
legitimate boxers do i'm not sure he's
not doing that and probably more that's
what i'm saying about the knockout of
tyron woodley because it was just a
regular boxer who's just coming up and
what does he have six fights
yes i don't know something like this
what does jake paul have yeah oh yeah
something like that right five no i
think james that was his sixth and then
looking at a post he had where he said
six and okay soon six no okay so he's
got five fights now anybody who had just
five fights
who's like doing you know small cards
and then knocks out tyron woodley tyler
whitley says i'm gonna try boxing and
some guy starches them with one punch
and talks mad [ __ ] like wow that guy's
hot
right but the fighter doesn't uh a 5-0
fighter who's knocked out five guys
isn't
saying i'm ready for canelo
like no guy but do you do if you're
crazy and you just talk a lot of [ __ ]
it's not like canelo's like waiting to
fight him canelo's got a lot of things
he's doing he doesn't have any time to
be waiting around on jake paul
he's not really gonna fight him he's
gotta fight golovkin in the rematch if
he if he beats beval he's got things
lined up